within the grounds of the Chinese
Consulate in Manchester a protester is
being beaten by masked men who dragged
him in
he's seen being kicked and punched for
at least 40 seconds before a police
officer steps in and pulls him to safety
Bob Mann escaped Hong Kong because of
violence like this he never expected to
be front and center of it in the UK
unbelievable
ridiculous
yeah and uh
actually that moment
um
I was
thinking that I might die inside because
that's no surprise that they would do
that as well as the cuts to his face
Bob's left with bruises all over his
body they like
a gangster you know they just doing
things like gangster
it shouldn't be like that it's not in
China you know this is
UK
why
it started as a peaceful pro-democracy
protest which quickly turned when
consulate staff ripped down cartoon
posters of China's president they deemed
offensive
but it was the apparent involvement of
the consul General himself pulling Bob's
hair and watching on as he was attacked
which is cause for concern
we approached the consulate for a
comment but they didn't respond
protests outside embassies and
consulates aren't uncommon but rarely do
we see them escalate to the kind of
violence witnessed here it is now up to
the police to investigate and determine
what actions should be taken if any and
for the government to decide whether
they make any diplomatic response
the prime minister's office said these
reports are concerning but calls are now
growing for the foreign secretary to
summon China's Ambassador in Britain for
an explanation we have a rich history of
accepting protest so this sort of
behavior is not typical I think our
foreign secretary need to set a good
example draw that red line that this
sort of behavior will never be accepted
from anyone on British soil what
happened in Manchester has left many
like Bobs scared and even more angry but
this is now a much bigger issue which
could have huge diplomatic consequences
interman Rasheed Sky News Manchester